adrian pro ça tu veux je suis désolé
messieurs réservé à la police on est des
filles de tampa inquiète dans ce cas je
dois voir vous assigne en fait on on a
quitté nos fonctions maintenant et là on
assure la sécurité pour un groupe de
rock qui s'appelle stryper paix tant que
l'ennemi ne parviendra plus opprimés mon
peuple je vais c'est lui maintenant ça
c'est la parole de dieu on va dire que
leur chrétiens s'aggrave et qui disent
ah ouais bah personnes jeudi que des
trous du cul 1
voyez vous je croyais que ce treiber
s'était séparé et ils se sont reformés
pour une tournée âme à jérusalem où et
ils veulent renforcer la sécurité
on aimerait mieux ne pas avoir à en
passer par là mais mais tu sais comme
moi il faut faire avec notre mon frère
ah ça c'est sûr en quoi puisse vous être
utile on cherche du matériel pour ce
n'est immobilisé et capturer notre
prochain sourire tu vas adorer ce truc
là j'y suis déjà passé tu peux y aller
huit mois pacifiste mois passé 10 mois
tu prêt va si vite mois six mois
nos pays nos gammes au cinéma le 11
septembre